Somebody has someone actually get with and they do something
about it. That's what needs to happen. Either one, someone needs
to get them
or I need to do something. Someone has to do something to themselves.
>> Hey yo, why' you why'd you delete a 44minute stream
here? Mom's basement stream number one.
Let's do >> He also asked his community if it was time
for him to start up the pumped up
I know that I feel like there might be some solid content. Every
time that Darius starts up his stream and then he deletes it,
there's always a decent chance that uh
that there's going to be something funny going on there. Okay.
Oh, is he crying? >> It's the same.
>> No, I I Dude, that was crazy. He looks like he's crying.
Anybody
has allergies? >> Uh, I went live because someone said
I have five minutes not to prove I went live today.
So, I was like, I'll just go live and then I'll end my stream.
>> I actually think it's allergies.
>> Yeah. I don't really
>> No, he's crying. There's also tears.
Did you see that? >> So, I was like, I'll just go live
and then I'll end my stream.
You see? Look. Look. Clear as day.
What is he crying for? I don't happen. >> Yeah. I don't
really
want to stream for like
>> until tomorrow.
>> I am going to start doing Tinder again. So, that's going
to be very fun.
>> I'll do that.
>> The [__] is probably my
>> Oh, it just makes me into a ghost.
I have to figure out how to fix that.
make the camera bigger.
>> Hannah Dumpton then if he's back on Tinder. Oh, right.
He was back together with Hannah in Canada, right?
>> Doing Darius content was banning anyone who mentions
his name.
Wait, I banned people who mentioned Darius's name.
We just need to chill like good old >> I don't think I
do that. >> It'll be fun to get back into Tinder.
I'm just not sure if I could like do it right now cuz I just
I Okay, I'll be real. I had no idea. I only saw that he was live.
I had no idea he went live and was like crying about stuff today.
This is This is awkward now
I'm going to keep watching.
I'm not going to I'll say trust me
I should say if Michaela Peterson looked one 100th this sad I
would never have mocked her while reacting to that video.
This guy is actually sad.
It's just stupid. I can't stream dude. Like this stupid like
actually my [__]
like dude I I can't like I can't like go outside. I have to like
worry about this. My lawyers handle it. And it's just like dude
like I don't want to stream in my [__] house dude.
>> I just want to point out that Zena didn't your you own.
Very impressive
your own ass like that. He's not on house arrest. He literally
can't go out and do things that aren't going to put him in a
bad light for his court case because he's incapable of controlling
himself and he did that to himself.
So like as much as as much as he's like crying and sad and like
oh this my up you own up. There was no reason for it. >> I
want to be inside right now dude but I can't even I don't even
feel like
my figuring out dude. It's just a lot
So no, I need to like figure that out.
Says I'm in Dublin, Ireland.
Okay, I think it's my VPN.
All the petty cases are a lot. It's a lot, dude.
It's all a lot, man. Dude, it wasn't a lot when you're collecting
those like those like $1,500 paychecks for like I don't know
10 hour live uh 10-hour like IRL stream where you're harassing
Zena and Chuvie, right? Like $1,500 a day when you're making
that that sweet sweet cash. It wasn't a lot then. It's a lot
now that you're like your lawyers are like, "No, you have to
stop streaming. You have to stop like talking about this
>> And I'm just not getting I've done I've done so much,
dude. Like other people keep say like, "Dude,
they're like, "Dude, you didn't do anything for anybody. You're
just a bleach." And it's like, dude, like what the did I do,
dude?
Like what the did I do, man? Like
Oh god, I I just saw somebody join. respected guy I just followed
and he's like uh Darius chatter. I just saw him in Darius's chat.
Maybe he just loves Darius content from any angle. Okay,
I have a feeling he's not going to like
I did I didn't know he was going to be crying when I opened it.
I did. He was I
I didn't I didn't open this up as like a
as like a I'm going to mock Darius today. I'm not even mocking.
Okay.
I'm sorry. I'm not going to miss any of
This is where we were.
there Oh, hold on. Was there more lore after Darius got in trouble
for sitting next to Zena outside court? Not really. I think that
was basically it. I feel like from that point, he basically decided,
"Oh, I'm not actually getting in any more trouble for this."
I think that's basically where he cut out.
Oh, wait. No, no, no, no, no, no. You're right. He actually went
to Canada and missed a court date. He did do that. And then they
were talking about him having a warrant out for his arrest because
he missed the court date. So, I don't know if that actually happened.
That's that's like rumors from the chat. I don't know if that
actually happened.
>> It's time to take control back. I literally have no
I have no means to defend myself, dude. Like
I like didn't I just I just didn't think
I did not think anything would get to any point
of where anything would ever be
because I thought like I'm like on the same wavelength as like
other people on
>> Oh
yeah, that's right. I think we just didn't want to be responsible
for Darius getting like we didn't want a fed post on Darius.
That was basically it.
Now it's like days and weeks later or whatever.
Yeah.
>> Caring about other people.
>> And like
>> like I'm rude. I'm crude. I'm a
But I'm not going to like destroy someone, dude. Like, dude,
Hannah even knew I was right out of d
everything would be fine if Hannah didn't leave again.
And it's always like people that I put so much time into that
just
>> troll the out of me, dude.
It's never the people that I don't No,
Why? Why does this Why did you make this? This is during the
prison streams. What the
meme right here? Okay. Jesus Christ.
Ah, you guys are sick. You guys are sick. You guys are actually
sick people. They'll put
the two >> or like
>> Hannah was caught with ice and Darius walked in on them.
No, that didn't happen. Sizzling cakes. There's no way. You just
making up. >> Spend that on. It's never dude. It's always
the same people, dude.
Man, this is rough. Darius a [__] but it's genuinely
tough seeing this down and out. Seeing him this down and out,
I'm guessing you're saying. Um, it used to be difficult for me.
I used to care about Darius. I used to like actually
like not to like a what do you call it? Not to like like a friend
or like a family, but I used to like want the guy to succeed.
Unfortunat I've watched him like he's crying after punching himself
in the face
and and I've watched him punch himself in the face like a hundred
times before this and so there is something where like after
I've watched you do it enough there is like a reduced reaction.
I'm still not I'm not like elated to watch him cry or something.
It's not like it's not like I got that much hate for him,
right? It's not like I got a bunch of hate for him on in this
case,
but I also don't feel bad about watching it. I'm
Yeah, this is this is literally Where's Zezy? This is literally
the Mitch Jones cycle. This is actually just precisely the Mitch
Jones cycle. Cuz here's the thing, Darius could go live from
his desktop. And Darius is very capable of doing entertaining
content from his desktop.
He is a He's a funny guy. He could just go live. He could just
do his content. He would pull he wouldn't get a,000 viewers.
He wouldn't get 1500 viewers. He wouldn't be hitting like the
crazy highs that he was with like the Shu Zena content that he
was doing,
but he would get viewers. He would do well. He's just not consistent
enough. And he's like, yeah, he's just trying to I don't know.
I don't know what he's doing to be honest with you.
desktop Tinder streams were goated. They were pretty good. Although
it was always unfortunately for Darius, okay, he's also like
way more entertaining when he is like in a bad place emotionally.
Like the funniest Darius has ever been were the postsushia breakup
like cheating getting cheated on by Sushia finding out about
it and that breakup and him putting on like the Joker makeup
and losing his mind. Those streams were like totally goated.
They were incredible
it was amazing. Okay, I like the re element. The re element was
okay. There was something like in just
I don't know. There's something unspeakable.
this unspeakable
man. I don't even know how to say it. It's like I can't put it
into words. Okay, I can't put it into words how and why those
streams were incredible, but they were.
You got to make money to handle this [__] How am
I, Dude, how am I supposed to stream when people like I can't
go home. People like just send the police to my house every day,
dude. Like
I had people calling animal control on my dog, dude. But you
like I don't know what the to do, dude. Like I don't know. I
don't >> as [__] up to call. Dude, do not [__]
with GMO. What the [__]
Okay, Darius, I understand
with Darius to some extent. Okay, do not [__] with
GMO. That's
>> What the [__] to do like ever, dude? Like
there's a counter.
>> It's like I just have to quit this [__]
dude. I can't like I can't do this [__] anymore.
My [__] head, dude. It's like so Dude, the people
are so awful,
God damn it.
God, now I feel bad. Now I Now I feel like I have empathy again.
Now I feel bad for this. >> The people are so And that's
like real
>> And it's just funny, dude. And it's funny. And it's
going to keep being funny, dude. It's going to keep being funny,
dude.
No way.
So is that the wallpaper that just came down? What? I'm
Dude, what the That wallpaper just came to >> go live.
Go live your [__] face. You if you're my ser telling
me to go live and I'm like, "Hey, I'm going through something.
Kill yourself. Just shoot yourself in the head.
>> Nobody will miss you." >> It's like a It's like
a green It's like a green screen or something. A dude. That That
was green screen to make himself like transparent, right? Jesus
Dude, nothing going nothing's going right here. I got to move
my avatar so not in his way.
>> We'll go up here.
>> So love
Yeah, frenzy breeze have this crazy like weakness for human emot
like people feeling genuinely bad and like they don't have a
way out of like a situ. Yeah, I feel like genuinely bad for people
even people who are some themselves sometimes not good people
like Darius.
>> Yeah, I do. I feel bad for him.
>> He has a way out though. Yes.
>> I can't even get this green screen to work, dude. >> Dude.
Uh this is what I'm talking about is like when he's not somehow
when he's like not doing what things just like come together.
Things happen there. Things happen around him that make it like
some of the I'm telling you happens like this all the [__]
time.
I dude I don't even know how to explain it to you guys.
>> I don't need it.
I tried making his screen work. It's not It's obviously not working.
I just taped it to the wall the this life and bought
nothing even behind me. I don't even know why it matters.
M going to be on stream. They don't want anything to do with
this. Dude, it's
in the last like
>> 3 months.
It's just
>> and I can't even talk about it. It's like even with
my ex, dude. It's like,
>> there were so many issues in that relationship and so
many times I should have just not talked to her anymore for the
crazy she did. And I let her back in so many times, dude. And
I and I did and I did stuff for I did I did I did stuff
>> I didn't just sit there and do nothing and just leech
and
>> I he
forgets a lot of that relationship. He just he >> then
I like I I liked M dude like everything like up and
>> he's under he is under spiritual attack right now. Okay.
He needs everybody to pitch in.
Guys, pitch in. And listen,
the spirit is in fact
a whailing woman, okay? A whailing a whailing woman. A He needs
us all to join hands. We need to do some some wiccan ritual.
Okay. To save him. Zena. Zena is actually casting
a spell on him. It's a curse and we need to join hands and save
him. Okay.
Bro, imagine him and Really just doing gym stuff and going the
the improvement
They should do that or he should do that. Um, that would be good
for him and I would not begrudge him that. That would not be
content I would be reviewing on my stream.
Okay. I I do think you should do that. I do think you should
do something like that. I think he was working hard at the gym
when he was hanging out with Rally. He probably still is now.
I do not think that would be the content to end all content.
>> Dude, I just [__] trolled the [__]
out of me, dude. I don't even I'm not even for
like I just like like why.
right. Well, there you go. There's a stream. Uh,
>> he's trying to end. It's 16 minutes in. This goes for
44 minutes. I'm going to
Tinder when I come back.
Uh, probably not actually. If we do, maybe I'll change my location
back home and we'll maybe do it when I come back home. I got
to figure out
what I have to do for this situation. My lawyer said we'll follow
up Monday.
I don't know what's happening.
my ex is trying to make sure I don't go to jail, so that's good.
But I shouldn't even be in this situation, dude. It's like I'm
I'm already dealing with >> No, I'm leaving this up. I
like this. I'm leaving this up >> so much, man. It's like
This is like the Mitch Jones cycle, okay? Go live, cry, get some
donations,
figure some out, get all the empathy from the people who like
see you as a weward puppy, and then
come back in a couple days once you feel a little better. I get
it.
So jail, I'm not going to go to jail regardless. It's just annoying,
dude.
I would do a day max and get out. It's It's just so annoying,
>> Wait, so that must be that he has like an actual warrant
out for his arrest and he is going to end up in jail again. It's
kind of weird that he's going live and showing that like he's
aware that he's in trouble and he's not turning himself in.
I didn't do anything at all last month and I still I come home
and I still have to deal with and then because I'm I just I can't
even like
>> Wait, do you not see it? I feel like the only thing
that could possibly Are you talking to me or did you quote somebody
else? Hold on. is like if you're asking me if I saw it.
Oh, I see. I see. I see. Something else. Never mind. Never mind.
Never mind.
Did he do we actually have like confirmation that he missed a
court date? Is that Is that a thing we know for sure that that's
what happened? Cuz I heard it and people say it, but I have no
like confirmation from anybody that's reliable at all.
just 4K.
I have to
stay in Bumbuk nowhere. Rayford, North Carolina. Look at Look
at where this place is on a map.
Ain't no way. He's just like, "Look, I'm just going to dox myself
real quick and uh I have to be here right now.
This place is next to
It's near a third world country.
>> I can't I do I don't even know where the I am.
Is I think this is where they shot Aladdin right down here. I
think this is where they shot Aladdin.
Am I crazy? I've heard of this place before.
>> I have nothing to do here. I'm just stuck here with
nothing. I guess I'm my dogs and that's keeping me sane. But
>> why does he do that? He's always done >> I just
need to like
>> booger inhale
>> beach like 2 hours away.
>> Yeah, the beach is going to change me, dude. It's so
[__] up, man.
>> Sorry. You're just trying to help, but it's like, bro,
>> I'm trying to train
ground. Oh, good.
>> Why are you there?
I just need to I can't be at the house, dude. Too many people
are like doxing and like trying to with me while I'm like working
with lawyers on trying to figure out what to do about a situation.
It's just it's just too much. And I can't have people like trying
to [__] with me, dude. Like
like having my exgirlfriend like and all like or whatever dudes
community like like trying to report me and I just can't I can't
deal with that right now. I had people like I made some announcements.
I was quitting streaming. I was doing a joke. People were sending
animal control to my house, dude. It's like I just can't I can't
I can't be at that house. I just can't be around all this.
It's like
you have to get your life with this.
I just am not in a position to to be able to monetize
the chaos.
Uh so I have to sit there and lose money to spend money on hotels
or driving or whatever and then just watch happen. So, it's like,
yeah, it's we're at the point where it's bad. And the the the
real root cause is,
>> okay, here's the moment for self-rowth. The real root
cause is your inability to handle the emotionally stressful situations
leading to you crashing out, spitting on Zena or like throwing
like actually throwing hands with Zena, right? Like you constantly
re-engage. You constantly play into this cycle and you're about
to accept personal responsibility for this, Darius. I know it
right now. I feel it. I can feel it. You're going to do it. I
believe in you, Dar situation with my ex and getting the the
protective order getting granted. But it's like
because honestly, if the protective order didn't get granted,
I could just do whatever the I want. But since it did get granted,
I'm cooked. And then this with my
Why, dude? All the reason that protective order got granted,
like 100% the reason is that you went to the courthouse and
streamed her
when it was the hearing for the protective order. You idiot.
It's like, but it's like, dude, like,
it just makes me so incredibly
depressed that I consistently
put a lot of stock and emotional stake in the people that I No,
his thoughts here are, "It's my fault for trusting Zena."
But no, that's not it. like outside of any trust for Zena, he
went to the courthouse and recorded her at a hearing for a protective
order she was filing against him. That was insane. That was his
fault.
Listen to his plan a few months ago when he was so upbeat about
it. Oh well, hold on. Maybe. Let's check it out. Let's see. Let's
see. Let's see.
>> So, let me let me ask you, how likely is it that you
that you'll >> The more times I go to jail, the better
the content. So, if I could just fraction out my jail time from
the statute of limitations of like 90 days, there's no longer
a thing. We could do more. So, as I've used notice, by the way,
with the money coming in, I have a big burst of money coming
in 1 month and then I could just sit on that for 3
>> 90 days. The three >> No, don't worry. Frenzy
Freeze. We're watching this explain why he's a total [__]
right now. >> Break rule will go away and then I just do
something crazy again. So, I have court in 2 days. Okay, I'm
going to get off of all the charges because I'm not
>> What? What are you planning on doing for your defense?
Do you have an attorney?
>> So, my attorney is not responding to my messages, but
>> I I sent them all of the clips they need and I think
I'm fine. So, >> you sent them you sent them kick kick
>> Okay. I said, to be specific, I had somebody send me
just a bunch of Twitter links
and stuff
and I just put it in. Now that I'm thinking out loud, it sounds
really dumb. They said they said
>> Bet that happens a lot. >> And it was an exclamation
point at the >> Who said thanks? Your attorney.
>> By the way, my video is not working.
it's working.
>> This is just so sc It's episode. Literally nobody understands
what you're talking about. Take end cuz nobody is from Germany.
>> Okay. So your said thank you for the for the clips.
Correct. >> Thanks to be specific.
>> Um also move. I don't think it's a good idea for you
>> communication we had >> for me to what one PC
stream this Dan. >> That's it is
>> don't worry about it. Okay. All right. Um so okay. So
they said thanks. What clips did you send in your defense? That's
what I would like to know right now. Sorry. What are you being
charged
>> So, I'm being charged with violation of protected order,
assault,
battery.
>> Oh, sorry. No, assault would be the thing. No, battery
and it's not battery. It's assault. Uh, burglary.
>> what did you allegedly burglar?
>> That's That's the Gatorades, right? He burgled Gatorades.
>> Walk through Japan scene on YouTube. >> The alleged
the alleged claims are one, I was throwing eggs at
uh a Merc off the perk. Uh that was assault. Uh the alleged claims
are that I was throwing eggs at a guy named Zukorar,
who used actually, if you guys know me, he's a DGER. Uh exterior
went crazy, squatted at my house. Uh
squatted in your house. That's not That's not very landlord of
you. >> You didn't charge him? >> Yeah, I actually
got him evicted still.
>> Uh we were charging him, but he decided to just stay
like but then we So luckily we were able to kick him out because
uh he agreed to leave when the police came and then he cried
to come back and squat and then like we had to go through 13
different cops to get him to leave until one that was there the
night that he agreed to leave came. But anyway, and so and they're
accusing me of burglary because we did like a thing where like
I took my Gatorades and liquid death out of his car, but he was
saying that it was burglary at the police report. If you guys
whenever this is done on the 20th, the police report, he literally
types ducker Z in the police report that got me charges in it.
>> And it's like it's like [__] It's not even
like it's actually up because I'm I had I It's like a burglary
charge is a class A misdemeanor which is another $2,000 on my
lawyer. So, it's not funny.
>> wait, I thought you had It sounds pretty dunker Z to
me, buddy.
Stop committing crimes. Who's got the liar liar clip? Just stop
breaking the law, man. >> A public defender.
>> What? I Well, of course I >> I don't think you
get a >> You do? But I didn't want to get one. I wanted
to get a reg regular lawyer, but the cost of all that together
was too high. I was talking like $8,000 just for this case alone.
And it's for three like
>> So, you do have a public defender,
>> I have something. I have a person I'm emailing.
That's what I have. >> Okay. All right. >> Okay.
Have you Darius, have you
Uh-huh. I So, you do have a public defender. I have a person
I am emailing. >> Prior to this, have you uh been in trouble
with the law?
>> There's that one thing with
the person who just went to jail uh all years ago. >> So,
what's so what happened? So, let's let's just get some context
there. So, Zena is in jail now. Um you know, and you can probably
clear this up. I think it's probably known, but that first shot
she was shooting at uh um Adriana, right? Okay. Yeah, she was
running away. Okay. And then later on she shot at the random
person.
>> Well, no. I think she was trying to merc off the perk.
Uh, but she was with three other people and one of them happened
to be a bystander. So, I think she just >> So, bystander
got in the line of fire. >> Yeah. You know what's crazy?
You know what's crazy? That girl who got shot is the governor
of Texas's daughter's best friend. So she's like
I was like I was like bro >> she's like out already and
I don't think she's in Did she get all the like dropped or dismissed?
I don't Does she have any Did any of that stick?
I don't know if any of that stuff >> like Okay, >> Kger,
I'm looking for you. Where's Kger at? Creger would know. Creger.
Did any of those charges stick? >> I was like, "Okay, this
can't be anything." And then the girl's name got released and
I was like, "Who's this?" And we see her there's pictures of
her on like her Instagram with like the governor of Texas's daughter.
I'm like, >> she's done." Do you feel safer that she's
in jail now, Darius?
>> Uh, no. Because at any time, I still need to be cautious
of what I said. I
>> shot with a paintball gun. Zena shot some people with
a paintball gun. >> Speak about what exactly happened in
the court. But I had I I've never spoke to a judge before. And
when I spoke to that judge, I realized uh listen, this court
ain't reality, bro. Like, you can't like just say like, "Oh,
this makes sense." And then they're like, "Yeah, they don't give
up."
No way,
dude.
Listen, I talked to the judge and I realized Discord ain't reality,
bro.
Dude, do you remember his arguments there? He's like, "Dude,
there's no way. I just I know for a fact we got her cooked."
And Ice Besid's like, "I'll defend you, dude. I'll show up to
court. I'll be your lawyer." It's like, bro,
>> about anything that
>> this was all so predictable the entire
>> It's been It's been a fun to watch. Okay. It's been
a little bit fun to >> You have to say at all in any shape
or form. So, even this conversation right now, uh I don't even
know if it's like allowed uh because the conversations that were
h being had in the courtroom were ridiculous. But the judge was
like, >> ridiculous." How?
Like let's say for example someone said that like let's say I
said hey Mr. Mootin uh you have a speech dependent [__]
and I and I added you in Discord. Stuff like that was like brought
up in court and they were like yeah this is like bad like it
was like I'm obviously like joking with you like I'm not like
being serious >> but like stuff like that was brought up
and then that was like that helped the >> Got it. So you
have to be accountable for what you say.
>> No it's okay. You have to be you can joke around. >> Okay.
Like you could joke like being hel being held accountable for
a joke isn't like it's like me just like like people just on
Discord just at you and be like yeah like you're a [__]
Like it's like you could just say that it's fine. It's not me
being accountable. It's just like >> Just a bit of curious.
>> Can you
literally
did he just forget the lesson he said he learned 30 seconds ago?
Did he go Discord's not like your arguments on Discord aren't
handled the same way in real life.
stuff got brought up that I said on Discord and was used, you
know, in the case against me. And then and then Mutton's like,
"Oh, so you're held accountable." He's like, "No, there's a block
button there." What? What?
>> Explain to me like I understand you had a on again off
again thing with Zena. Why is it that Zena and Merk off the perk
seem to hate each other so much?
>> Good question, Dan. Thank you. >> Uh I think
uh their personalities just don't clash very well. I think >> I
feel like there's more more to it than what you're left on. >> I
think you're you're like trying to edge something, but >> I'm
not I want to know. I'm I want to I want to be a knower. >> You're
on you're on CNS News Network right now and we want to know.
>> That's true. >> I think one person likes to troll
a lot and the other person is very aggressive. It doesn't play
like that and they just don't Well, >> okay. Who's a troll?
>> I say that Merk probably is more of a troll. Like M
likes to joke around, have fun, and just >> Dude, do these
guys know [__] anything about anything?
push things like in a trolly way. I don't think that what's her
name does >> Are you in a relationship with with
>> We're not in any thing I think right now. Like I think
we're not really talking at all. >> Okay. You're not talking
at all right now. But previously
pointed things. We're not allowed to communicate or anything
right now. >> Oh, you guys can't even talk anymore. >> Well,
so because of the case, >> but before were you, you know,
a thing? >> No. Well, him and Zena were were a
Now I'm worried about if him and M were a thing.
>> Wait, so there's a there's another Oh, there's another
court thing with with Merc in you as well. >> I have my
core stuff on. >> Yeah, he just he just told you about
>> The 20th that I should
>> with like all my >> with Zena. Sorry, I'm getting
confused. >> No, I every everybody Zukor, the DDG, MK,
and everybody. >> You're just doing it all in one go. Just
all three. That's well that's literally what the Okay, so pretty
much the judge was I I had two different court dates for two
different things and then the judge was like, "Listen, bro. This
is like ridiculous. Like this is like like we need to just like
put this all in one day and make it sooner because it's getting
out of hand because I have >> I'm being I'm being told
that last night that you and M were together.
>> I don't know. No, not >> He has no idea about
that, Dan. He's got no clue.
>> Okay, that's fine.
Um,
no, that's fine. That's fine. So, okay. So, you may or may not
be in a relationship with Merc right now. Correct.
>> are you in a Sorry. Okay. No comment.
>> You can say you can say no. >> I just So, this
helps. Okay. This helps fend off the empathy that was being felt
for this stream, >> right? Where you like go a month ago
and Darius is like, "No, I'm innocent of everything. Like, I
dude I these people are making up these it it helps." Okay. It
helps knowing that he's
he was being he's being told by judges. He's being told by his
lawyer, "Hey, you need to stop. You need to stop. You need to
>> We're not in any relationship. We haven't communicated
since like >> it helps. >> Uh
uh what's this month? July July like 4th. Second. >> Okay.
Is there like restraining order that she has on you or vice versa?
>> I wouldn't know that. >> I think Zena has a restraining
order on him. Not
up here. >> But you would know that if Merc had one on
you. I think due to the family assault cases, they provide a
thing where like you can't talk to the person for until like
work. >> Yeah, but you would Yeah, but you would >> So,
do you have three different cases going on right now? >> I
would know. >> Or is it two? >> Yeah. Yeah. Just
It's very confusing. Go ahead. Take take the R. >> Take
the R. All right. How many cases do you have right now that you're
going to do at the next court date? Are you doing three or two?
>> Hold on real quick. It's like It's like we're talking
to
It's misdemeanors against three different people, right? Four
different charges, three different people. >> Someone from
the wire. It's like how many cases you got? You got four. I got
>> I'm doing four. And it' be easier for me to communicate
about this after the >> yeah. But we're talking to you
right now, though. So, >> but it'd be better if we did
this on another date. >> Dan, more specific. >> We
can We can do it on another date. So, okay, that's fine.
>> Guys, it would be really easy. It would be way easier
if you
it just struck me how much worse it is that he missed the court
date, that the judge explicitly said, "This is all really bad.
we need to do it all in the same day. And then he missed that
court
The judge was like, "Hey, we're going to do this all in one day
cuz it's important that we stop whatever this pattern of behavior
is. We need to stop it. We need to make sure this isn't happening.
So, we're going to put this on an earlier day. We're going to
put all of your stuff together so that you can be here." And
then he didn't show up
>> Fine. But in the meantime,
>> I'm doing four. He's got four. >> You're doing
four cases.
>> So, you got one with Zena, you got one with the other
guy. >> What are the other two uh about? >> What
are you being accused of? >> So, one is >> I'm being
accused of assault class A
>> Class A burglary. Class Criminal
>> I could have sworn that yes, he was in Canada when that
when that court date was supposed to be happening. He was in
Canada with Hannah, I think.
But some Gregor Samson says he overslept. I don't know if that's
true. >> Class A violation proective order. >> Okay.
Got it. >> And those are all against other people. Um other
people. Yeah. >> Three different people. >> Three
different people. Okay. Three different god dam. So we're at
five people then total.
>> Do you not know math? No. There's three different people
in four different >> Three people. Four cases. Dan, get
up. >> Sorry. I'm trying to keep up. I'm sorry. I'm trying
to keep
all of your [__] in a row. How long is this the longest
Dan's ever gone on the podcast without talking about Hassan?
I think he's like he's like kind of going through withdrawals
right now. He's not really able to follow what Darius is laying
out. He's just like he's trying to he's like can I make a website
or something about Hassan, right? He's like back in the background
messaging people to code a new website about Hassan
>> Uh yeah, dude. I'm not even like during the thing the
hearing or whatever. They were just like, "Bro, this is so
they don't even know how I got to this for the situation of for
a class A assault." For a class A assault and we're talking about
what what I mean alleged that it was an egg. They were like literally
just they they were they were baffled when we we were talking
about at the >> So those cops are overcharging you. It
sounds like
>> I don't know until I do my case. I mean, if people feel
like I went overboard, then you know, >> that's what uh
you know, I'm curious. You know how they have they have the Mary
thing here, but there's only So, you got three of them here.
You got Zuk Zukeria, Zena, and uh Merc.
>> Oh, I think I pushed him. >> Yeah, definitely
talk about one of those people, Darius. That sounds like a great
idea. Why don't you say for Zena right now and just, you know,
double down on yourself over >> He wasn't going to answer
that one. >> Good for him. >> He got out of there.
>> Hold on. We got a We have a breaking news clip. >> Breaking
off the looker. >> Oh, about if you were like following
a lot of work accounts. Uh, Darius re
>> Darius rejoined. Okay, Dan, there you go. Drag him back
in. >> Take that one off. >> All right, it's off.
It's off. >> Okay, hold on. >> Uh, we got to go back
for our Japanese
>> Good. Good. Good. Good. So, I want to know what what
are your life what are your life plans you have right now? Like
what what moving forward? What are the big moves? >> So,
one of two So, actually, so this is the craziest thing ever.
I'm so excited for it. So, I found out that you only need like
five racks to buy a propeller motor. So, I'm now going to be
the first streamer that just gets by by propeller motor. So,
I'm going to learn how to use that in the backyard. And I'm just
going to start like propelling on top of buildings and just doing
all my transit via propeller motor. >> What do you mean
propeller motor?
>> Darius is like something out of
there.
I don't even know how to explain what Darius is. I'm gonna This
is like an It's Always Sunny skit and Charlie is like talking
about using a propeller motor to get places. I I don't even know
what the [__] he's talking about.
>> Yeah, it's a helic what's it called? >> You mean
the thing that they all the >> Yeah. So, you want to you
want to kill a bunch of Israelis then? You want to be like, are
you joining?
>> He's doing he's doing a paraglider.
that's interesting to come on a a stream, a live stream with
Dan of all people and be like, "Yeah, I got a paraglider, bro."
I'm just like those people who went over the wall in Israel.
No, that's not parag motor. It's the thing you sit on and it
has a big fan in the back.
>> I know what you're talking about. Yeah. You think you're
going to Dan, have you ever seen one of those? One of those things
that like with a big fan in the back and the parachute. You ever
seen one of those, Dan? Dan, are you aware of what I'm doing?
Dan, are you aware? Dan, hello. You're going to fly around on
>> Is this thing Is this thing?
>> What else would you do? None. I'm just going to put
in my backyard and just start flying around. >> Okay. I
mean, I'm pretty sure you need like permits. And >> you
don't need You don't need a license. You don't need anything.
>> So, if you wanted, you know, you could fly this from
your backyard to downtown Austin and fly around is what you're
telling me. >> Yes. Yes. Yes.
>> I wonder how this guy ever ran a foul of the law. It
sure seems like he has a great grasp of it. Okay,
now I can totally fly around, guys. What the Why wouldn't I be
able to fly around? There's no license. >> You should do
that. I think you should >> There's power lines. >> He's
hit power lines.
>> Hit power lines. And also, he googled like, "Can I have
a param motor?" And then someone like the Reddit thread and it's
like, "Yes." And he was like, "Oh, this is legal." Okay, >> there's
no law against it. If only there were a law against flying objects
around in the sky. If only there was like
some sort of FAA or something that handled objects flying off
the ground over a certain height. If only there was like a federal
agency that handled like greenlighting that kind of thing. I
don't know. >> Look up. You're allowed to use it. You could
do it whenever you want. It's just if not wise. And obviously
if you power lines, you're going to just
>> ATF. No, not the the ATF wouldn't do this. Sherry, what?
It's like a flying. It's like a paraglider. He's like,
oh, unless you're talking about him having an AK-47 while he
flies around with that thing, which who knows? >> You do
whatever you want.
>> You may be
Okay, first off, I feel like you may be wrong. Okay. Uh, and
the reason I say you might be wrong is like obviously, you know,
you don't want to be >> Oh, wait, hold on. I did actually
forget ironically Trump fired everyone. Dude, government shutdown.
Darius, now is the time. Now is the time.
Now is the time. You have your moment, Darius. Trump shut down
the government just so you could actually break the paraglider
out.
Paragliding near an airport, for >> Yeah, obviously there.
But you can't drive to an airport. Well, besides the like drop
off and pick up, like you can't drive on a [__] >> But
you But you can't paraglide over the drop off and pick up either.
I think this is a good idea, Dan. I think you should. And I think
you should go with >> You don't even know. Like you can't
you can't paraglide in circles around the airport parking lot.
You're going to get in a lot of trouble for that. >> This
is great. He should >> if there's Well, there's Well, there's
probably power lines, so there's probably a negative factor there.
It would have be really funny. They probably have anti- drone
guns and they'll shoot you down. >> That would be funny
as that actually did happen on stream, but I don't think that's
going to happen. I think it's literally just going to be cuz
I'm I'm I'll be honest, I'm scared of heights. I >> Hey,
I totally believe that you don't need a license for ultral light
aircraft or something, Frenzy Freeze. But I do believe you almost
certainly have to check in with some agency to make sure that
you can actually do the things that you want to do.
>> Almost positive. They probably have anti- drone guns
and they'll shoot you >> That would be funny as if that
actually did happen on stream, but I don't think that's going
to happen. I think it's literally just going to be cuz I'm I'm
I'll be honest. I'm scared of heights. I don't even roller coaster.
So, I'm probably just going to go about as tall as like
Wait, what?
Guys, I'm gonna get around. I'm gonna get around purely by paraglider.
I'm scared of heights.
Okay. Why did you just get a motorbike or something? What the
are you doing?
Uh, he's going to get like 15 ft off the ground and panic and
just beline like straight upwards and come straight back down
to like do a loop-de-loop.
>> Wait, can you have camera here? Cuz camera work. >> Look
up a param motor video. It's nuts.
It's nuts. What do you mean param motor?
Param motoring.
Param motoring. This is like the
buying my Chinese $3,000 Chinese param
>> This is unironically express motor
>> Dude, Darius.
Darius would kill himself within a day on this. If he bought
one of these things, he would die within a day. It would be so
crazy if he got one of >> It would be completely [__]
>> I love it.
Jesus Christ.
Dude, if that guy Did that guy just about die like on the screen?
Did that guy literally just come within hitting that tree of
dying?
You see how he like maners around that tree? I don't know how
close he got. Look like he got kind of
like he's like right there, bro.
Holy [__]
I wonder if this is like D like sorry obviously D but I wonder
if it's like I wonder what the margin for error is like how easily
you recover [__] up. I have no idea.
Hold on. I just realized how real the dream could have been.
Okay, now I don't advocate anything like this, but imagine getting
like 15 of these. Okay,
I totally disavow the joke of and showing up to Will's wedding.
Okay, just the look on his wife's face for like two
That would be insane. You wouldn't want to do that. Obviously,
it already happened and we're never going to listen. I'm just
saying. I'm just saying.
I'm just saying. Okay.
>> Okay. All right.
That's pretty cool. >> Yeah. Darius got to get one of those.
>> Uh I can get you up there, I think.
>> Show me your camera.
Wait, don't you >> What is the mileage on this, do you
think? How far can you get on a tank? Probably pretty far because
it's probably not a very high strength motor.
No, maybe it is a powerful I don't know. Yeah, I actually don't
know.
I I have no intuitive understanding of how the physics for that
work.
Yeah, I got no idea actually.
I could see it being like like that to actually get enough like
strength from the fan to propel yourself and stay up that like
maybe
maybe that like actually requires a pretty strong motor more
stronger than you'd expect. But I'm guessing it's like mostly
Yeah. But wait,
I don't know
or something. >> No, you're probably fine just to click
>> Um you see it like it's not loading. I'm going to leave.
Oh, what? There he goes. Why would he leave? And he's gone. What?
And he's gone. And he's back. >> No, he's back. >> Hold
on. Let me Maybe there is edit channel. All right. You're in
Dan's cam
>> Okay. This is what we all wanted to see. This is what
we all wanted to see.
That was definitely like a shattered tibia right there. 100%.
wait. Did you see what the crazy thing was about that? That the
fan blades hit the ground and shattered and shot out everywhere.
Holy
holy. Watch this. Watch this. Watch
He clicks that. Dude, this guy just got hit, didn't he?
Oh my god.
Bro, these things this thing's like three grand. You're like,
"Oh, I can fly for three grand. That's crazy." And it's like,
"Yeah, you ever [__] up in any way, it immediately
shatters into a thousand pieces. Good luck.
That's That's like crazy to be going around an obstacle course
like that.
>> Okay, one more. One more real quick. >> Behind
me, you can see the moment >> investigating Anthony Vela's
near fatal >> Anthony Bella crashed his aircraft while
flying approximately at 48 mph.
>> 48 mph. Come on, baby.
Oh my god.
Holy [__]
Holy
Jesus Christ.
Oh, that's that's horrifying. >> Miles. Come on, baby.
Oh [__]
I'm okay. I'm okay. I'm okay. Where's tape deck? Where's tape
deck? I need the edit. I need the edit right now. I need the
edit right now. Tape. I need it. Please. Where are you? I need
it.
I'm okay.
Oh my Oh my god.
Jesus Christ. Okay. Are we Darius join rejoin this? We got to
watch the rest of this and then we're finishing Daryus's bot.
Okay. It says >> Yeah. Yeah. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. Video allow. Save changes now.
>> Wait. Let me join. Leave. Rejoin. >> Okay. Then
he means leave and have me drag him in again. >> Yeah,
that's what he means.
>> All right. Is he on?
>> Yeah, you're on. >> Yo, there he put that. >> He's
on. survive.
>> That's good. >> Dan, you need a haircut like that.
So, I'm saying I'm thinking just for like like if I paraglide,
it'll be from down there like to the top of that house at it'll
be like I'm like on a little like a mini jetack.
>> Nothing wrong with that. >> That's a good idea.
>> What even happened there? The wind just twist his ropes.
I don't even know, man. Apparently, listen. Apparently, they
interview with Anthony,
Holy. Wait. Holy. He
that's a glove, right? I think that's a glove. I think he his
hand up. I don't think that's a
Jesus Christ.
Where did your empathy go? Um, for this guy,
I'm sorry.
This guy signed up for what he signed up
It's a little different, I think.
I think. Jesus.
Flying the Luna, dude. No way. There's no way this guy went.
Okay, we're going to investigate what happened during the crash
and then I'm going to interview him and then I'm going to go
fly the same craft he was flying.
That's the glider behind him all bent up and Yeah. I don't doubt
it.
Oh, dude.
Hold on.
>> You met her at a funeral? >> Yeah. Dude died in
a hang gliding accident. What an idiot.
Oh, I'm hang gliding. Honey, take a good picture. I'm dead.
>> What a freak.
Sorry. I just That's That came to mind immediately for some reason.
I have no idea why.
We watch the actual investigation part here.
You know what? Let's uh let's see. Reflex gliders accelerate
by decreasing the angle of attack, but they don't do it in a
linear fashion. They actually do it. This is way too nerdy. I
I can't do it. I got Listen, I'm in Darius mode. Okay. I'm not
in brain engagement mode. I'm in Darius mode. Maybe we watch
the explanation after or something. Okay. >> And there's
not a single there's no power lines or anything in sight. >> It's
just trees. But like I could just >> You open
a little bit of runway possibly. >> No. I'll probably have
to >> to practice for the first couple times probably.
But after that, this used to be an abandoned place. So, my idea
before was before these houses were built. Uh, but I will probably
have to find somewhere a little more open road for sure. >> Maybe
just a little bit. >> But after after I get the hang of
the everything, I could easily just glide above these houses
with these. >> You think that those houses are going to
Are they going to complain about you? >> I mean, they're
going to be jealous. What are they [__] they going
to say? >> They're going to say some terrorist is out here
with a paraglider trying to do another
attack. I mean, what are they going to do? Dude, >> you're
the only person that has trauma of that, man. Like, nobody else,
no normal American worries of
>> dude is Darius based actually. What the [__]
Darius Darius calls out the JN when he sees it. What? >> Palestinians
or
whoever them. Nobody has to be worried about that. They're going
to be excited. They're going to think I'm like a circus performer
or >> Nobody's got to worry about that, Dan. >> I'm
on a hot air balloon.
>> It's not. It's a very loud device. You know that, right?
It sounds like a
>> that sounds even better for a >> That's literally
a It's legal, man. He can just do it. >> Dan, stop discouraging
this guy from making a multi,000 purchase that will be completely
wasteful. Stop. Stop. Let him waste his money. >> He's
telling you. >> Yeah, that is legal. >> Are you listening
to him? It's legal, man. I think I mean you guys prove me >> No,
I'm I'm on your side. I think you should do it.
>> I don't think it's legal.
>> Give him a $5,000 >> for sure to do this. >> Okay.
I I listen, everything's an investment, so I will have to get
out like a loan. But like here's the thing. I know that the content
will be so good that it'll easily make it back in like two days.
This is like this the past like five minutes of the stream have
been like a microcosm of Darius's entire 20s. Like the entirety
of his 20s.
It's just the whole time. Listen, I don't really have the money
to do this. I'm going to take out a loan. I'm going to do it
anyway. The content's going to be good. And then literally doesn't
do any content with it. Has Darius ever made thousands in days?
Absolutely he has. All that Shu viena content he was getting
almost 2,000 viewers, getting like 1,500 2,000 viewers. He was
definitely making thousands of dollars a day at that >> The
problem is that when you're doing it, no one's going to be able
to hear you talking cuz you're going to be talking and it's just
going to be
>> that actually
that's something I noticed with the motorcycle I bought as well.
Did you have you guys seen that? >> No, I didn't know you
bought a
>> That's just wrong, Dan. That's just wrong. I heard this
guy just fine.
Right. We heard this guy just fine.
>> At 48. Oh,
>> 48 mph. Come on, baby. >> 48 mph. Come on.
>> Oh, but
>> I bought a sports bike, but it's so loud. No one can
even tell. Like, what's like going on? >> You're going
to need some serious RTX voice is all I'm going to tell you.
Like, that RTX voice is going to have to be to a maximum, and
you're going to need to have that microphone inside of your inside
of your throat.
>> Weird. Okay, that was Darius talking about his legal
cases and how he's totally gonna win. This is now Darius after
he has totally lost.
Shouldn't have [__] around with his legal cases one
month later. Okay, we're back to this this stream. Um, if you
weren't here earlier, if you didn't catch the earlier parts of
the stream, okay, I don't know how to catch you up really. Darius
is just in a sad boy mode because he skipped his court date.
Okay, he is now probably going to have to spend at least a day
or two in jail and
he is kind of just self-pittitying over it. His own bad decisions
have caught up with him and he's struggling >> and know
are going to like hurt me.
>> Oh, also he is just being like he's just too nice and
too considerate of people he knows are going to hurt. consistently
put a lot of stock and emotional stake into people that I know
are going to like hurt me.
I got incredibly lucky
with keeping distance in from
like Burke did Burke wanted the best for me, but like
she very much was not in a position to love me for who I am or
what I do or
be patient with me. And that's fine. That's okay.
But I lucky luckily did not
>> impact my mental
as much as
>> bro this there's like one ice beside chatter named Kimmy's
nose job that I'm just like that's so up I don't know that's
just so up knowing how >> much Kimmy hates her nose job
chop >> I don't know it's it's messed up I don't know what
what else to say there
or
currently that
>> Hannah is
or my And
>> so yeah, it's his breakup with Hannah's with him, I
guess. >> So once playing victim and make a
>> I think I am making a change. Time to heal. Abby, you
should
your online presence.
nice save,
dude. Abby, you should kill your online presence. Wow. Wow. Saved
it. I Dude,
>> you're part of the problem, dude. You're a like like
like I I can't believe these women have the audacity to come
and show their stupid nasty faces anywhere. Like it's just so
like Sushia too. This
unblocks me and then like wants to like make jokes about like
oh like oh Zena followed me on on Twitch. Yourself
on live video
on the AI app not in real life.
You stupid [__] [__]
>> Does anybody know why all of these women want to torture
him? It's like he did something to them or something. Why? Why
do all these people just torture him for no reason? I have no
It's unbelievable.
>> Like you people are just evil.
girls are ruthless. No emotions at all. They're just all These
people are just
You people are just so
man.
You paying attention to it means you know better. I have stupid
friends that are for some reason still friends with this psychopathic.
So I get it in my Instagram reels pictures of or videos of her.
You know what? I could just block it and never see it again.
That's not gonna happen because I'm gonna unblock it because
I'm gonna do the thing again where I'm
>> dude. He's got there's the wolf inside of him that is
slightly self-aware is like it's after like a decade is starting
to slightly fight back. That was amazing.
I'm not Dude, cuz I'm going to block it, but I'm not cuz I'm
going to unblock it and do it all again.
Dude, way more way more than the the the queen shaman from the
conspiracy theory Jubilee episode. Darius has multiple personalities
inside of him and they are waring right now. Okay. >> Like,
you know what?
Pictures of or videos of her. You know what? I could just block
it and never see it again. That's not going to happen cuz I'm
going to unblock it cuz I'm going to do the thing again where
I'm like, you know what? Maybe they're a different person or
maybe, you know, I do miss them. So, then I'll maybe block them.
So, I'm not even going to go through the hassle.
>> I'm just going to wait till I'm bored.
>> Just say you still follow her. You're not lying. I did
it.
When I found that out, I didn't follow her. Nicholas Mana was
liked one of her stupid reels cuz she decides she thinks she's
going to be a streamer again.
new friends? I need to just get out of that. I just need I need
to live on my
I need to be alone.
>> Bro, I don't know why Abby is in his chat. It is
>> I need to stop. I need to not date anybody. I need to
focus on the gym and I need to focus on using people. That's
literally just has to be what I do. either use people,
>> go to the gym, >> get my money back up, make back
all the money I spent on vacationing with my ex, with my ex,
sorry, with Hannah.
I didn't spend that much money on Hannah. I just extended my
trips and did more extravagant things because I was with a
I just make that money back. You can make I can make that money
back in like literally 3 weeks. It's not that bad. Zeus collab,
What?
three weeks. How much money did he
dude? Do I have to go back and watch those Toronto those Canada
streams? Was he balling out? How the [__] did he
spend that much money? >> Zeus is another person where
it's like, bro, like
like
I'm not joking.
I wish I could get legal revenge. Like,
this is the piped Hannah. This is not a different Hannah. This
is the Hannah that was getting piped. He met up with Hannah again.
I don't know why. He was in Arizona. He met up with Hannah, I
believe, and Really. And then I think her and him and Hannah
either drove they must have driven to Canada and then they were
streaming in Canada together. He did like a stream with Vegan
Gains. He went met Vegan Gains in Toronto.
But I don't know what he was doing that he spent so much money.
I don't remember him streaming that much. I wish I could go to
a court house and say, "Hey, these
deserve me to do whatever I choose to do to them."
Uh, yeah. Your honor, have you considered that all eight times
I spit in that woman's face, she deserved it each time? Your
honor, have you have you considered that when I egged this woman
in front of my house that she deserved it every single time?
Your honor, have you considered that when I stole that [__]
out of Zeus's truck, he deserved it? Your honor, I need you to
consider these arguments for me, please. like Zeus pressing XD
lol charges on me so I have to do XD lol theft classes because
I don't want to spend lol $4,000 on a l lawyer for his lol
content of pressing charges
should warrant me to just do whatever I
I should be allowed to just pin someone down and punch them.
>> Oh Jesus. I thought that was I thought that was going
a different direction for a second. Whoa. >> Until I just
feel relieved
and that should just be allowed legally.
And then when I feel relieved, >> it's getting really dicey
right now that he went live. He's talking about assaulting the
people who are pressing charges against him. One of which has
an
restraint or protective order against him. This is stupid again.
Why the [__] would you go live and talk about punching
now? He said I No, he said these people. He was saying these
people. He might have said Zeus there. I don't know why you would
do this. This is some crazy [__] man.
I think we can see why he deleted this. I guess so. >> We're
fine and then all is well.
How about make smart decisions? >> The savory assessment.
Yeah. No.
>> So when somebody
>> did something I didn't
>> Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. I want to see if anybody
said, "Please stop saying these things." Yeah. Someone said,
"Clip G." Clip G. >> I feel relieved.
We're fine. What the? And >> all is well.
Uh, clip G.
>> How make smart decisions.
>> So, when somebody
>> I don't think that's legal, buddy. >> Says I did
something I didn't do.
And for some reason, that's probable cause. What do I do there?
You want me to go back in time and never have interacted with
the person?
I'm not in an Avengers movie.
>> What do you want me to do?
>> You cry like a I cry like a [__] and I get
active like a man. I can do I can do both. You can cry as cuz
it's normal and it's healthy. >> Yeah, that's kind of cool.
>> But just don't sit there and cry. I beat the [__]
out of people. I had a person try to make fun of me and try to
insult my manhood to my face and I rocked this.
Uh, wait, why why was he crying again? Was it because of all
of the crimes he was being charged with? All the people pressing
charges on him? And he's like, "Guys, listen. Somebody questioned
my manhood. I knocked the I I beat the out of him. Dude, this
is
you're understanding, Kilo. There are there are parts of Darius
that are just really funny and really entertaining.
And if there were just slightly fewer total piece of parts,
uh he's not like unredeemable.
There's something there, but it's
ah, man,
>> let's say you had the means to move out of Austin control
place. Where would you rather bet?
>> I wanted to move to Arizona, but I don't I don't think
I want to be around Hannah. I don't know, dude.
I'm not dating any girls that were born after the year 2000
or engaging in any sort of activity with any girls born after
the year 2000.
>> That's bad news. You already knew it.
>> Yeah, but she trolled me so hard, dude.
She trolled me so hard, dude.
I like cut off people for her and she was like, "Yeah, yeah."
I'm like, "Bro, that need never needed to happen."
>> But it's like
I don't mind playing. >> That girl's like a decade younger
than him, too. What is he doing?
>> Playing your little game. I care about her. But it's
like, bro,
>> you lost Danny and you're going to lose me and Kitty
next.
You think you're on the same level as
Daryus, you lost Danny and you're going to use you you're going
to lose me and Kitty next from I am Cyborg. I am
are you trying to tell you it wasn't worth it?
>> Tan says he owned you. That guy doesn't even own his
kid.
>> Jesus. Wasn't
she 19 when they met? Yeah. Uh, she was 19 and he was what, 27?
I think
>> you tell that you're not going to put up with her trolling.
I have to figure out how I feel.
She wants to like
just do what we should have done at the start, which is just
hook up and
talk. But it's like I already
>> It's fine. It's like I'm not even that big. I'm not
even that upset.
It's fine, guys. It's fine. Oh,
that's brutal, dude. He fell hard for Hannah the first time,
too. Do you remember? like he didn't even want to stream anymore.
He just wanted to go on like dates with her. He was just like
he like stopped doing his job entirely. He was just going on
like dates with her. And then I think she wanted to just keep
it casual and he it didn't work out that time either.
>> It's just
like like I didn't even lose her. I'm just I'm just like
>> I just I just hate
I just hate that I just involve myself with people that just
just lie to me about what they what they want.
And I and I get
with other people. I've done things like like with my ex Iund
I like I spent so long just like trying to figure out what I
wanted to do to her with her and I just didn't know.
I just didn't know because everything was always so bad all the
time. Like we'd have like two weeks of just
good times and it'd be two weeks of bad. And I
thought maybe I could figure out like some way to make the good
times go longer and the bad times shorter. And then sometimes
my methods would work, but then I'd up somewhere.
>> It's called abuse. I went through it too. Abby
I think you
or like
uh he like hates Abby so much.
It's It's just like [__] up seeing her post. Not
I I'm like not laughing that uh laughing at Aby's comment cuz
I think she actually was abused. I think that's actually true.
I'm just laughing at how
Darius is literally the abusive person. >> [__]
up somewhere.
it's called abuse. I went through it too. Abby,
>> I think you are like schizophrenic.
>> Stop chasing.
>> can't really take it out on Z. Zeus
>> just needed to not press charges. What are we not understanding
there? Zeus is Zeus's fault that I went to jail.
imagine just just imagine having this opinion or imagine thinking
this in general.
Listen, it's actually I know I I know I stole from this guy's
truck. I know I committed crimes. I know that the cops won't
prosecute me just for somebody's word that I was on video doing
these things, but like Zeus just didn't have to press charges.
Has he has he just given any thought to that? Like, hey, maybe
you could just not you could just not commit the crimes. You
could just not do the crimes.
>> It is Zeus's fault that I went to jail. He said I stole
items from him and then he said I was
vandalizing his car.
>> You did vandalize his car. >> And that paired
with somebody saying I was assaulting them.
>> Yeah, you 100% assaulted MC and vandalized his car.
>> These people are scum.
We had Squeeze in the house and we had people in the chat hyping
up Squeeze to try to press charges to ruin
Prawn's
for because they're upset that they're trying to get money back
from a kid that's to scam them
because it's funny. These people are
parasites, man.
They can make it. >> Dude, um I'm sorry.
Unless there's one possibility with Legacy and Prawn, there's
just one possibility and that would be if they came out and said,
"Actually, you know, we were joking. We we actually was a bit
weird with Squeeze and he wasn't supposed to press charges."
That's the only case where I consider them blameless. Otherwise,
they actually deserve to go to jail for the night.
They lied to the cops about they did on video. They deserve to
go to jail for that. You're like a total [__] for
doing that. >> You know, whatever money they're making
right now, and that's like straight, but like Cowboy said call
him. Why the would I ever in my life call that guy? Why would
I ever talk to Cowboy?
Be genuine with me right now. What the [__] is Cowboy
going to tell me that is going to be new information?
>> Uh, Cowboy is Shuy's cameraman, I >> Is he going
to tap into some Native American
secret like ritual and then start giving me profound truth?
Egging cars is illegal. I didn't egg his
That's the thing. I didn't egg his car.
I did not egg Zeus's car. Squeeze did. Squeeze egged his car.
But he said we both did it. So I had to deal with that.
>> And then he said I stole waters. And then literally
within 30 minutes goes ahead and says Darius didn't even steal
them. He paid for them. And he knew
And he knew that.
Here's what I'm I not joking. I'm not I'm I'm not even joking.
These people, the only way you're going to get satisfied and
know these people are going to change is if somebody I'm not
Uh we're about to see another moment that is going to get played
in court and going to be the reason Darius goes and spends another
night in jail. I I just I feel it. I feel it. I can sense it
coming. Okay. He's about to say some crazy again. The only way
we're going to ever deal with these people is >> I'm not
joking. I'm not I'm not even >> I'm not joking. these people.
The only way you're going to get satisfied and know these people
are going to change is if somebody, I'm not joking, somebody
has someone actually get with and they do something about it.
That's what needs to happen. Either one, someone needs to get
them
or I need to do something. Someone has to do something to themselves.
These people
in the head and there's nothing that will that will change their
mind on anything unless it's a it's it's shock
I'm I'm not joking. I'm being as serious as serious as possible.
The only way these people will do better in life is if you have
something that will burn into their skull because they don't
view anything as real. Not a single [__] person in
this community views anything or any of these people as real
life humans. And if I
I Okay,
that's true and that's
bad. Okay, that's bad. That's true and it's bad.
Unfortunately, he kind of signed up and he joined the CX like
and he he signed up for a lot of this [__] and he
was he was okay with it when he was making
If only there was an easier way to opt out. I don't know.
He's literally just entertainment. Yeah, most people don't care.
That's I guess that's a realization you have to come to eventually.
Most people only care about as much as you can entertain them.
Outside of that, you are not helpful. You are not useful to them.
didn't get my [__] gum. I'm not even joking right
now. If I did not get my [__]
is calling. Do you understand the levels? Like do you do you
do you get it? Like, please tell me you get it. Zeus calling
to talk to me. Do you think
do you think do you think that's a reasonable thing to do? Nothing
I'm saying is incorrect.
Please tell me it's
Hey,
the guy you raped or assisted in
that guy's calling you.
The guy that
Wait, what?
Wait. Huh? >> You is calling you while you're venting that
you got
>> Oh, metaphoric. Metaphorically.
Met. Sorry, I also just perked up. Metaphorically though, he
means
>> like Are you
don't know why he Why he say it like that. I don't know why he
said it like
>> this is not a uh
this is not an this is not an outlet to communicate. How are
you understanding what I'm saying? So, do >> Oh, I also
don't know if I said but anonymous. Thank you for the gifted
sub 22 minutes ago. Thank you. Thank you.
how do I explain this?
>> They still got to prove it. And it's only 500. Not a
huge thing against your name for 500. What the are you talking
about for 500? You
talking your crash outs are legendary because I'm not wrong.
When I crash out, it's because it's deserved on some det. biggest
loser on this platform for some reason is like their baller like
like dude imagine in what world are you seeing somebody post
online that they're hanging out with a deadbeat dad and it's
like supposed to make you want to watch it. Only this website
do you do that?
Only this website do people do that and then some people watch
it and they pay them to to to stream that.
Like who like what the
Wait, is he talking about Destiny or Dan? I I lost I lost. Hold
on. I have to go back. The dead beat dad and it's like supposed
to make you their baller like like dude, imagine in what world
are you seeing somebody post online that they're hanging out
with a deadbeat dad and it's like supposed to make you want to
watch it. Only this website do you do that.
Only this website do people do that. And then some people watch
it and they pay them to to to stream that.
>> Some people idolize the deadbeat dad. It's crazy. >> Like
who? Like what the >> I agree. That's kind of up
and he gets 500 viewers.
That's at least $20 an hour. That should be at McDonald's.
A call center something. He should not be here.
>> Oh, I'm just a kid.
>> I even know there's [__] music playing.
You just said, "Let me play >> 500 viewers is a lot more
than $20,
Um, for Darius, it might not be. I'm not totally sure. I think
they said once you started getting banned, you're going to lose
like KCIP rate or something. For me, it' be more than 20 bucks.
I know >> I didn't realize there's music playing >> cuz
I' I've never been I've never been like banned from kick.
>> And where should you be?
I here.
I am real. I'm
uh am not a fake.
I am in real life.
Uh maybe I don't provide the best content. Maybe I provide a
lot of content.
Uh but I provide a personal personable person.
Uh because I'm >> personal personal a personal personable
person. Personal
personal personable
personable personal
personable person. Yeah, I said it three times. Not very fast.
>> You're just chatting and I'm not allowed to do IRL because
if I go IRL anywhere, someone's going to call the police on me
and then I'm going have to explain to them the situation because
everyone's unhinged. Dude,
are you heading to the boat?
You need to hide. I don't even need to hide from the law. I'm
hiding from chat.
I'm hiding from you guys. I'm hiding
I'm not even hiding from the law. If I had to turn myself in,
I'd do that. But I've been
>> I just opened Twitch and this is the first thing that
popped up. This is not my fault.
>> Who does Twitch think I am?
>> I'm not that guy. Okay, that's [__]
>> Not cool. >> I just had to point that out really
quickly. I'll go back to the Dar spot and we'll finish it. >> Advised
by not even my lawyers,
police to just wait till your lawyers handle it and just don't
get pulled over.
Dude, no one raped you. Are you like
You hiding from Merc?
Do you guess Murk doesn't call the Merc doesn't call the police?
Despite
I I don't even think the night that the police came, she called
the police. >> Bro, M doesn't call the police. Did he just
say M doesn't call the police?
Bro, MC infamously calls the police. What the are you talking
about?
>> MK didn't call the police. I'm not hiding from Merc.
I It's It's some random
skitso chatter. There's She did.
She literally admitted she did. She only called one time, >> I
guess. I don't know. I don't I'm not even trying to def
I wonder why everyone around you keeps calling the cops on you.
>> Yeah, I must be the problem.
>> He says sarcastically.
Yeah. Is it? Yeah. I'm the problem. Yeah. I'm the problem. Four
different crazy girls come after me and I'm the problem. Yeah.
Okay. Whatever you say,
to start eliminating bad influences in your life permanently.
I don't think that's possible.
I think I have an innate attraction
things that harm me because I hate
I think that
if there's something that is not going to harm me, I'm not interested
in it.
I will continue
>> that is not the entire picture here but >> a l
cow and I will do this again with you guys in maybe 3 months.
So
uh see you guys maybe with merk in a month. Uh see you guys uh
maybe doing some [__] in a month. Uh, you know,
I don't know. Uh, but nothing's going to change until I blow
my brains out on live. Uh, so until that happens,
um,
I'll see you guys tomorrow.
Uh, I'm just going to say Buzzy did it better. I
did it better.
That was a pretty wild stream.
I I did like that somebody was able to link the the URL or sorry
the video of him talking about his cases from before cuz [__]
kind of crazy. Anyway, I
I don't want Darius to do that. I would like him to not kill
himself. So, hope he figures some out. Hope he comes back better
than ever. Okay,
there. There. I
h
All right, that's it. That's it for us, guys.
It's use online.
Nobody online. I know. All right, I'm out. I'll talk to you guys
later.
Have a good night, everybody.
I'll be back tomorrow. All right, bye-bye. Good night. Good night.
Good night. Good night. Good night. Good night. Good night.